How's my hair looking?
In March, I said US-China trade was "all talk, no action." Now, it's "all yelling, no action."
The yelling stems from American tariffs on up to $450 billion dollars in Chinese imports. Tariffs are a mistake.
They would hurt American consumers. They would hit Chinese companies which have done nothing wrong, along with the predatory companies.
China does heavily subsidize its firms while enjoying open competition practiced by others.
It steals and coerces transfer of American intellectual property. It promises to improve, but it never does.
We should respond to that, just not with tariffs. The US should target large enterprises owned by the Chinese government.
The Communist Party wants these enterprises to dominate the Chinese and global economies.
Because they are owned by the government, they can be held responsible for policy.
The US should start with a small group of bad offenders with regard to IP.
They should not be allowed to do business with American consumers or companies. They should be hit with global financial sanctions.
This maximizes the pressure on bad Chinese actors without taxing Americans. It's more focused and more justified than tariffs.
What do you think about the US Responding to China with tariffs? Let us know in your comments.
Also, let us know what other topics you'd like our scholars to cover in 60 seconds
and be sure to LIKE and subscribe for more research and videos from AEI.